Then you do this.
Okay. [laughter] Goody.
>> Dude, this guy's out of his >> You guys, this
is our hate [laughter] >> Dude, what the is >> I'm
making a dog whistle. You rub my hands together to symbolize
the French
>> Just go out for this, guys. >> I'm calling this
one the Larry Ellison. >> I didn't do the meme. I didn't
do the meme. I'm just saying this. Okay, this is the Larry Ellison.
Hey, give me Tik Tok. Work for Israel. Give me CBS. Work [laughter]
for Israel. Give me the American government. He bought Marco
Rubio for $5 million.
Let me buy your company
together. [laughter] >> No way.
>> We've got this. We've got the the Anna Casparian stuff
as well. We could check that out. >> Ana Kasparian with
her Karen rant. >> I don't think I got a chance to see
>> Sicked on her.
>> I don't know that story. >> We check that out,
too. and a casparian >> this morning now. >> I'm
not playing any music now. I just paused the music.
>> Um, hold on.
>> As I was walking,
>> I got to get some caffeine. I'm going to hit play on
this. And I'm getting caffeine right now. >> Jesus. Yeah,
I'm falling asleep. Okay, I'm going to hit and play on this.
We're going to check this out. And then
we'll see. I'm sure there's lots of I've got this. We can watch
some of the Hutch stuff. We can watch that Hutchia combo. There's
lots of [__] I'll be right >> My dog as I always
do. >> Oh, wait. Hold on. There's also We could look into
the chest thing, too. The chest thing seemed like it might be
interesting, but I might need some time cuz I've got all of his
VODs. All of the guy's VODs.
Oh, man.
I kind of want to look into the chest thing now that somebody
said this guy was acting erratic cuz I assume, listen, he died
like suddenly. I assume it's a Right. Nobody says it's a but
you find when when nobody says what the actual thing was like
that this guy died suddenly he's a young guy I feel like that
usually means right
>> I don't know I'm sorry I'm like I'm half paying attention
I have to dip out for a little bit >> sure no problem
>> what did you say queen
>> or overdose yeah something like that let's see
in the morning
>> um all of a sudden I was confronted by >> Oh boy,
this will be interesting. >> A woman who I've seen in the
neighborhood before, never had any issues with her. And since
I've seen her in the neighborhood before, and I never had any
issues with her, I didn't think much of
what was going to happen as I was approaching her. So, I'm walking
my dog. She's standing in the middle of the sidewalk with her
dog, and she her dog's going nuts, like unruly. And I'm thinking
to myself, "Oh, she's trying to train her dog. her dog, you know,
looks like it might be a younger dog, whatever.
And um as I'm approaching, she's looking at me in a menacing
way, like she has a weird wide stance. And I'm like, I still
am not thinking much of it. I'm just thinking, okay, she's probably
irritated with her dog acting like this. So, let me just go around
her. So, I literally walk into the street in order to go around
her and her dog. As I do that, she starts with her crazy, unruly
dog, approaching me and Charlie, essentially like sticking her
dog at me, but not letting the dog loose from the leash. Thank
God. Okay, at that point, oh, by the way, I'm listening to music.
I'm minding my own business. I'm trying to avoid her.
And then when she's like coming at me with her dog, I like take
my headphones out and I'm like, "What what do you what's going
on?" And she's like, "You're a hater."
And I'm like, "Okay, well, [laughter] obviously there's a misunderstanding,
so let me have a conversation with her." But she's like screaming
at me. It's 7:00 in the morning. And I'm like, "Wait, wait, hold
on." And then she brings up, "Oh, you were rubbing your hands
and making fun of the This is Canary Mission propaganda. Full
stop." And it's in reference to this. Let me see. Let me show
you what they've posted on social media. Now, uh, they claim
that I'm doing the happy merchant, uh, meme, which by >> which
of course she she would never do >> What What a terrible
time to have been walked away from my computer. God damn it.
I'm hearing everything. [laughter]
uh, you're a hater, Anna. Oh, boy. What did she call What did
she call it? She said this is of course it's just something propaganda.
>> This is Canary Mission propaganda.
Canary mission propaganda.
What? I don't even know. Sorry. Is that >> Canary mission
like this? It's this doxing thing.
>> Oh,
like stop anti >> antionist doxing like stops. Yeah. >> Okay.
Weird. Okay. All right. >> Full stop. And it's in reference
to this. Let me see. Let me show you what they've posted on social
media now. Uh they claim that >> it's definitely not in
reference to that. The touch tweet got way more heat than this.
Any Destiny tweet about this would have gotten way more heat
than this.
I don't know if she just doesn't want to call them out directly,
but those clips got way more way more traction than this. >> That
I'm doing the happy merchant uh meme, which by the way, I didn't
I I've seen that photo all over the internet before. I didn't
know it was called the happy merchant >> is that this originated
this edit where it places the happy merchant next to her originates
with canary mission is what she's saying right
>> um maybe
I it might originate there I feel like
merchant is saying >> but if you just saw
like if everyone just saw a clip of Anna doing it and then people
say it's the happy merchant like Hutch says it's happy merchant
that's probably not going to hit some random woman but if you
flash up very clearly an anti-semitic caricature next to Anna
doing uh this impression that hits with like everyone like every
normie understands what's happen there even if they're not like
>> I feel like it was the
I think was it who tweeted like oh the nose job really saved
her here actually somebody tweeted that I think it was sleepy
so props to him on that one okay the side profile really hits
hard >> I've seen that photo all over the internet before
I didn't know it was called the happy merchant meme. I don't
live in 4chan. Okay.
>> They call that an a happy merchant
>> and he's you say he's like a >> Oh, you're supposed
to be a man. Oh, >> very concerning. Very. >> We
were talking about one specific person. So, I brought that up
to her. I was like, I'm I was talking about Larry Ellison. One
specific person who wants to surveil us 24/7 so we're all on
our best behavior.
And then she immediately switched to a different uh agrieved,
you know, issue that she had that other issue that she's agreved
about, which I'll get to in a second. Go ahead. >> Yeah.
And so, look, uh I feel like the pro-Israel radicals have planted
so-called tropes all around us. So that >> That's true,
Shank. I literally cannot go, you know, a single conversation
without accidentally doing some some transparently anti-semitic
canard. Okay. Hey, I say somebody's a penny pincher and suddenly
I'm the anti-semite. Come on, man. >> You're never allowed
to criticize Israel in any way, shape, or form or in any style
or with any body emotions or with any words cuz everything's
a trope. Everything's a trobe. >> I wasn't even criticizing
Israel. I was criticizing one specific person. We're going to
show you the video in a second. Hold on. Go ahead. >> And
then Larry Ellis is later in this program, we're going to show
you a story about how he's trying to build these giant things
in Gaza. >> AI centers. AI centers, which meaning like,
oh yeah, obviously Israel is going to take Gaza. Obviously, we're
going to ethnically cleanse him. We might or might not use >> I
I do appreciate they're like, "Guys, guys, guys,
Larry Ellison really is an evil Jew." Like, okay, I just I know
I know they're criticizing, but he's really an evil, right? >> For
forced labor, but other than that, we're taking Gaza. So yes,
>> which by the way, actual facts, Larry Ellison is in
fact like taking over the world and he happens to be okay. I
don't know if there's a connection, but it's he is actually like
an evil guy. >> And Larry Ellison, who bought CBS, Paramount,
uh, and Tik Tok and expressly for the purpose of doing propaganda
for Israel, they're not even hiding it. They say they p paid
more for Barry Weiss.
>> I'm not going to lie, the thing that Anna was complaining
about in the clip, the whole like using AI and CCTV cameras.
People that complain about that [__] are like
>> Hold on.
>> Hold on. No, I don't I don't know if
>> I do know that this is specifically something you're
talking about that like you're going to be live in a surveillance
state, but I know this is like a different bone you have to pick
with with stuff that you were you were making this point like
kind of separately with the what like
univers universal ID, right? Like uh >> Yeah, digital ID.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I feel like it's it it could be integrated.
I feel like it'll be integrated long before it might be integrated
now in North America at least. Like people might be following
you well enough already. You're quiet. I wasn't talking perfectly
into the mic. >> What What's the like I don't understand
what people like if a business uses or like if the if the you
know government has CCTV cameras, whichever way it is,
cameras that have AI in it, what's what's the problem? >> I
mean, >> what's the problem there?
Tracking people around could get weird after a little while,
>> but they can track you around anyway.
>> you already gave up. You gave up >> They're not
supposed to cameras there. >> They're not supposed to.
They need like a warrant or something. I think that'll be the
thing is
there'll be some there'll be some system of encryption where
the government once they get a certain like warrant will be able
to go and figure out your location. Well, they'll be able to
go translate your location into like >> human readable
data or something, right? But this is like assuming that all
CCTV cameras like subs are the same thing. Like it's not when
we talk about having AI and cameras. If a business
pays to have this AI system in their cameras, it'll work for
their business. >> What do you even mean? >> There's
no inherent.
What the whole point is the idea is to have what Larry Ellison
in this speech thing is talking about having
using AI to assist with CCTV cameras and to help with surveillance
and and selling this. So the idea to me >> that doesn't
come across like, oh, the government forces every business to
have governmentowned CCTV cameras in their business that are
linked up to a government AI system that can track you around
at all times. Now, as with any tech, there could be like a government
back door in something, but that's not built in to the the premise
of having AI in CCTV cameras. If a business to me, it sounds
like businesses would buy this. You have to find
any obvious
that's like not something you mean feeding the camera feeds into
something where you like you basically put them out on the internet
so that this other company can use AI to track things in the
cameras then they're the people with all the feeds. they become
like the government in this hypothetical if it's centralized,
right? But if you're just talking about having AI chips in the
cameras that do something that could like follow people around
or know like when to shut one camera off, turn another one on
or some like this, that's like a way different prospect. I don't
even know what they're talking about in terms of I've never seen
the Larry Ellison speech. >> The Larry Ellison
Okay. Yeah. Well, the idea the premise that people are upset
about is just the idea that AI is being used to interpret data
gathered by CCTV cameras.
Like they hate that on its own. If you just say that to someone,
they're like, "No, no."
That that's like the experience I've had talking about this.
>> Sure. I can see why. Like I think people just don't
believe that, right? They don't believe if you are collecting
enough of uh CT CCTV footage somewhere that you wouldn't use
it for other more nefarious purposes, tracking people or doing
something else, right? Even if that's technically infeasible,
which
>> Okay. Sure. But so what that the issue then though isn't
about CCTV cameras or having AI and CCV cameras. And this is
what I try to say to people every time about this is the issue
that you have there then is about data and about laws around
data collection and data protection and what rights you have
over the the data that's collected about you. Uh, and you should
focus on that rather than crying about Larry Ellison trying to
make AI in CCV cameras because your problem isn't actually with
the idea of an AI analyzing data gathered by a TV CCTV camera.
Your problem is with the way in which the data is potentially
collected, stored, used.
>> Yeah, but that's literally like everything, right? That's
like you could say that's why like you could say AI and cameras
to like upscale people's faces, right? That could be AI and cameras.
If that's what he means, then nobody cares, >> right? This
it just all comes down to what he means by AI and cameras. >> Well,
yeah.
Even if it's like Well, yeah, but like even the idea that you
I don't know the idea that there's you you have a mindset where
it's like, oh, if they're collecting the data, that's not I'm
not okay with that or something like that. Like if it's been
stored at all, that's that's not okay or some. I feel like you
should focus more on just, you know,
I is focus on ruling out huge
potential
uses instead of focusing on your ability to control how your
data is used,
you know, your rights as an individual. I thought that that should
be focused on more as opposed to people just trying to rule out
different uses of AI, which it feels like is where the conversation
usually is. >> Um, [clears throat] yeah. I mean, yeah,
I would agree.
Like, it has to do with basically is anybody going to get enough
of this data somewhere where they could do something dystopian
with it? And ultimately, in the individual case, yeah, that breaks
down to your rights with data, right? But I don't know this
I you again, you just have to know the specifics. It's hard to
discuss any of this stuff in a vacuum. Um, I do believe that
Larry Ellison with the amount of infrastructure he has and all
the he has going on that he could be looking at doing something
far more nefarious than just, oh, we're going to do like CCTV
that I don't know AI CCTV.
I don't know what he even means when when he talks about that.
>> It was it was like a pretty short clip, but it's it
was the clip that Anna was talking about. It was what she was
referring to in that thing cuz I looked up because of that because
of that um
whole drama. I'll see if I can find it. >> Yeah. Yeah.
I'm much more concerned about the Shanks complaining about
>> Yeah, I think that was about Larry is buying all the
media. And >> so you're telling me the worst part of
horrifying anti-semitic act of imitating a happy merchant when
uh trying to pretend to be Larry Ellison was that it was inaccurate.
That it actually wasn't where he was his most evil. She she wasted
her shot. She had one shot at merchanting this guy in public
and she wasted it. It's [__] up. more. I'm in the
business. I know. They paid an outrageous sum. And then they
brag to the press about, "Well, that's because she's pro- Israel."
Then Netanyahu comes and says, "We're taking over Tik Tok and
we're singing about X, etc." And then they say, "And by the way,
they committed a genocide. They murder over 70,000 people." The
Israelis do, not Jewish people. The only people saying people
are pro-Israel zealots. Yeah. No one else says no one that's
in the legitimate space that isn't Fuentes or whoever, right?
But they constantly are like, "You said, but we didn't say no
one ever said Jew other than them." Okay. Oh, I'm sorry. Can
I do this? Can I talk? Can I say anything? >> Your existence
is >> so No. No. But Larry Ellison is an evil guy who is
taking over all of this media for propaganda for Israel. But
you're not allowed to rub your hands about it. You're not allowed
to talk about it. They say we're taking over media, but you're
not allowed to say they're taking over media. So, they're allowed
to do it, but you're not allowed to say it. No, I don't listen
to any of your stupid rules or tropes. All right. Anyway, back
to your story. >> Now, why this clip was cut so short,
and it's because he's talking about using AI G in like police
cameras on like squad cars and then body cameras to constantly
monitor and report stuff. And he like they cut off specifically
the first part where he says before he says citizens will be
on their best behavior. He says police will be on their best
behavior because we're constantly monitoring reporting everything
and then ends it with being specific about the places where it's
used like squad cars. Um and they cut that part off. They just
included the citizens will be on the best behavior. We're going
to have AI and cameras and it's going to be monitoring reporting
everything and and that was it. I wondered which group of the
the Jays you were with. It turns out you're one of the Ellison
Jays. The police will be right now. I see. I see. I see. >> The
police will be on their best behavior
because we we're constantly recording watching and recording
everything that's going on. Citizens will be on their best behavior.
>> Bro, this guy is like freakish. I don't know how to
describe it. Like whatever,
right? Isn't he like able to? >> I know, but he like it's
like there's
>> there's some adrenochrome [__] going on
to keep this guy
>> like 65
>> because we're constantly recording and reporting everything
that's going on. Um, and it's un it's unimpeachable. The the
cars the cars have camera, you know, cam cameras on them. We
we have I think we have a squad car here someplace. Uh but those
kind of applications using
AI, if we can use AI and we're using AI to monitor the video.
So if that altercation had occurred, it occurred in Memphis,
the chief of police would be immediately notified.
It's not people that are looking at those cameras. It's AI that's
looking at the cameras. No, no, no. You can't do this. It would
be like a shooting. That's going to be immediately that's going
to be an event that's immediately rep.
It's going to be and uh we're going to we're going to have supervision
and other words every police officer is going to be supervised
at all times and and the supervision will uh and and if there's
a problem AI will report the problem and report it to the appropriate
author uh person whether it's the sheriff or the chief or whomever
we need to um
take control of the situation. We have D, you know, same thing.
We have drones. We just if there's something going on in a shopping
center and I'll stop. >> It's like a totally nonsensical
rant anyway. Like I just I
>> business like selling it [__] you know,
he's like, "What? Dude, AI is so cool. that's going to like >> Yeah,
he just keeps saying AI. >> He's like des
like to a bunch of people that don't give a [__]
basically >> which is because I believe he owns like a
ton of the data centers that have all these GPU chips and right
like he's he's got like a huge investment in the infrastructure
for this stuff and from what we've seen we've been going over
the we went over like a I think a Hanking video on this >> like
the infrastructure investment in AI is like 100xing the amount
they're making from it right now. like they're they're spending
so much to build up this infrastructure, they have to keep selling
applications. >> Not quite that, but yeah, basically how
like all the AI is just like no money is being made back on it
yet. >> Yeah, it's like it's pretty wild. Fent is trending.
He is trending. What could this possibly be? I think he's back
tonight, right? Am I He's supposed to be back tonight. Oh, it's
a a cozer cliping canary for this. >> Oh god. I think a
really great example of this and like a like a a mining canary
for this is the rise and the popularity of like Nick Fuentes
because really for a long time Nick Fuentes was like deplatformed
in a lot of places and uh you know people didn't really associate
with him or deal with him at all but what's really happened is
that after he's gained enough notoriety and popularity
uh people have now begun coming to the table and I think that
he's normalized a lot of rhetoric and opinions that previously
would be considered unconscionable and just
>> I'm just looking at his chatters right >> Platformable,
but now because there's enough people that agree with him that
now is part of the global conversation or the cultural conversation.
>> Wow, Jasmine Gold guy is really smart.
>> Would you go to Aiden Ross' nominos
or sent $20? Would you go to AD Roth Stream Rewards event in
LA or Vegas if nominated? 07. >> Oh yeah, if I was nominated,
sure.
it's crazy. Sneo got unbanned. Fuentes blowing up.
Those guys won. Everybody Everybody who went to Kanye's for the
uh the presidential run. Okay. Everybody who went there, careers
are exploding right now. Big things happening. Who would have
thought? >> Milo Dong have a brain tumor.
Yeah, big things are happening. Okay, but here's the thing.
I'm just a baby.
>> why? Why does this exist? This from >> Here's
the thing.
I'm just a baby. But
okay. All right. What a goofy fellow. This this Nick Fentos guy.
What a goofy guy. Okay. All right. Are we back? We're finally
back to this. Okay. So Anakasparian in that clip kind of take
it out of context. Maybe not as evil as it seemed just like an
investor meeting trying to sell and you know make the money he
can off of all of his AI all of his investments.
Before we get to Canary Mission and the um propaganda they put
out there in order to get people to target me like
after she attempts to attack me with her dog,
the only thing I have on the top of my mind is I need to get
my dog to safety cuz I have a small dog, okay? He's 20 lb. So,
as I'm walking away, she says to me,
"Good luck to your husband dealing with you and I say, "My husband
loves me." And she responds with, "That's why we're trying to
get him fired."
To me, that was the sign that this isn't some lone wolf situation.
She's part of a organized group that's not just attempting to
destroy me. But >> wait, what is [__] conversation?
>> A matrix Caval I I guess. Sorry, I just
>> Hold on. Take a look at this. Can you Can you parse
what the conversation is that's going on here?
Uh, read from the top.
I literally don't know what's going on there. I'm very confused
by it. And a Kasparian's a targeted individual, I believe. So,
>> destroy my husband's livelihood when my husband has
nothing to do with my career. Nothing. >> I I I'll just
say there seemed to be some overlap here between an Anakasparian's
career progression and Candace Owens's. That is very disconcerting.
Okay. Very
very bizarre. It's very weird. I don't like to do with guy doesn't
even like politics. Okay. He works at athletics. He works at
a school. He loves his students.
>> I is Hutch replying with like AI or >> No, he's
just like being
>> I literally don't know. I don't want to focus on it
on stream, but it's just I confused. [laughter]
>> I'm I'm talking about your stuff, but I I didn't um
like I asked about this. I didn't want to bring it up on stream.
I don't know if you
care. I was just like confused. I just don't
>> I don't know if he I don't know if he replied to you,
by the way. I'm I'm referring to the replies from before. I I
I don't get it. I literally don't get >> His students love
him. >> He's getting defensive. He's going like defensive.
He's like, "Oh, my wife would say really nice things about me."
That's what he's saying. That's what he's >> Is that who
that is? That's his wife.
What? How is that an answer to a
>> It's not He's trying He's not answering the question.
and he's just being he's been a queer dude. I don't know what's
going here. >> I It's just bizarre. I'm sorry. >> But
they want to destroy him because he >> he clued the rest
of us in. Uh
Cherry asked Hutch what his political affiliation was and he
was like, "I think my wife would say nice things about me." No.
Oh, well, I don't even know. Okay. I I'm unaware of the Ogre
Boy post that this is mimicking. Somebody said that in the replies,
though. They're like, "Is this an Ogre boy post?" I found it.
>> Hold on. Am I connected now? >> Yeah. Uh I think
Wait, hold on. Talk. >> I am. I am. >> Okay. So,
it's not a um not a ship. >> Do you need your glasses?
>> Yeah, I do. What am I?
>> No, it's okay. I'm in. I'm in. I don't know where I
put them. I can't see anything.
Kind of blind. Okay. Thank
Uh, it's it's not a post, but you know, Ogre Boy did a tweet
like that and added Hutch and Hutch engaged with it. So, I like
I built off of that looking for like the same sort of um I don't
know,
>> But first, I didn't even know what name he was giving
me, but you guys said that's his wife.
>> I'm not apparently his wife. Yeah, I was asking him
a direct like question
because I want him to answer me. I don't know why he would defer
me to his wife.
So, no, I'm like asking for his engagement. And then he tells
me I don't know you and I'm not sure what that's to imply. Like,
you're already replying to me.
So, I'm not sure what the value in telling me that you don't
know me.
>> Wait, but haven't you guys done I thought you'd talked
to him before. I have talked to him before. Well, I've messaged
him before.
>> Oh, okay.
>> I don't >> Yeah, I don't I don't know. That's
why I'm asking. >> He's being really defensive. He's been
like super defensive, right? >> Yeah. I think he wants
to know like where this is going or something. And I just tell
me what you think your character is. >> Well, he's it's
like you ask him what do you think of yourself? And he's like
he just he feels like all that can possibly >> This must
be a trap. >> Well, it's not even a trap. It's like he
he thinks you're just like asking him to say bad things about
himself. Like he just his mind immed.
He's just like, "Well, I think my wife would say really nice
things about me." It's like, "Okay, dude. Okay, that's >> I
I just the responses from him are so confusing. I just don't
I don't know. It's not even that it's bad. It's like not even
I wouldn't even classify them as bad. It's I was Yeah, defensive
is fine, I guess. Odd odd stuff. >> I know. Um,
it just seems like he's giving me an excuse to not engage with
me before like really telling me he's not engaging with me while
he is like currently engaging with me. It's very
>> Yeah. I just I started reading it. I was just like,
"What happened?" >> Like I'm going to reply to you to let
you know that I'm not going to talk to
>> Like what?
just odd. Very odd. >> Guys, an unbearable
queer. I can't lie. totally unbearable queer. Though I do want
to watch the conversation with
>> I would like to
I would like to be able to have him engage with me. I'd like
to be able to have a conversation with him. Doesn't have to be
on stream. It doesn't have to be publicly on Twitter.
There are things that I find problematic with what he's done
and what he said. And if he doesn't want to engage with me, like
that's really frustrating.
And the last time I was frustrated like this, I did a video series.
Jesus.
Or we're or uh Hutch. Hutch. Just just send a DM Hutch be better
for you. Okay,
that's that'd be very cool. A Hutch Hutch video series.
Oh boy.
>> Hutch. Don't send a DM. >> Hutch thinking certain
people are deeply >> It's like a really really good person.
>> Oh yeah. Hutch is good. Did you ever watch the Liquid
Sonic Hugh Anthony video? >> I don't even know who those
people are. >> the You know Liquid Sonic, bro. You >> I
kind of know I kind of know Liquid Sonic cuz you I think the
meme is that you pay him to make videos for you to react to.
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> I'm sorry. I can't I can't I I
don't care about Hugh Anthony. I I I literally can't imagine
caring about Hugh Anthony. >> I'm sorry. >> That's
like part of the fun though.
>> It's like he sucks so bad. It's like epic. I watched
that guy for a little bit and he was like so unbelievable organized
handle it was it was really bad and he was like answering he
was like fumbling answering why he was gay or or or responding
to the fact that he was gay and it still wasn't
>> Oh my god. >> Yeah, it was pretty rough. I would
rather watch Anakasparian. So she said that this person sicked
their dog on her and apparently there's actual footage of it.
Wait, hold on. Just scanning. I'm going to call it now. Just
based on this, I feel like this woman looks
>> or is it just a is it just a picture? She's such a
>> I'm sorry. I'm just I'm imagining she's
than I could have possibly thought. >> That's not just
attempting to
>> It might just be pictures. I thought it
destroy my husband's livelihood when my husband has nothing to
do with my career. Nothing to do with Guy doesn't even like politics.
Okay. He works in athletics. He works at a school. He loves his
students. His students love him. But they want to destroy him
because he refused to put out a statement condemning his
>> could be
uh I
I just saw the funniest tweet. I'm not going to ever explain.
>> Incessantly, incessantly, they demand that he put out
a statement condemning his wife. He's not going to do that. Okay?
you're not going to get in between a marriage because your feelings
are hurt over my criticism of a foreign government.
Now, she said that and I was like, I gota I gotta call Christian.
So, I'm trying to get Charlie home. I call Christian. I tell
him what happened.
Leave Charlie, drop him off at home. Christian and I go downstairs
because he he wants to see who is this woman,
So, at that point, we approach her and I decide I'm going to
file a police report and I don't know this woman's name. I want
to have an image of her. I want to have a video of her. I want
to have a video of her dog. And so, get a load of her behavior
here where all of a sudden, now that I'm recording, she's pretending
like she's the victim when she's the >> Oh, it's after
the fact that she records who uh tried to sick her dog at me
and Charlie. and pay very close attention to her treatment of
her own dog, how her dog is behaving, and what she's saying.
Do you think it was appropriate for you to try to stick your
dog on me? >> I did not. >> Do you think that was
appropriate to stick your dog on me? You sick your dog? >> I
told you to stay away from me. My dog is barking. >> Was
that appropriate? Was it appropriate for you?
Get away from me. >> Can I [laughter] talk to you? >> No.
I >> Why did you try to stick your dog at me? >> I
told you to go. Because you don't like my political views. >> I
told you to go like this. >> I told you to stop following
me. Now you're acting different. I told you to get away from
me. >> I told you to get away from me. I told you my dog
is barking.
>> This is wild. Yeah, we all see it.
>> Stalking me.
>> It's just the the Karenike nature of both of these people.
>> They're both yelling [laughter] at the other person
and harassing them while not really disengaging. Just being totally
histrionic.
Are we do we really believe do we believe Anna completely that
this woman just came over and
berating her?
>> Do we believe that this woman came over and called her
anti? >> I I could believe it. I don't know. I I I don't
discount it, but it's not shown in the video. And like Anna just
like sort of slips in there sort of meekly. Like if it weren't
such a meek delivery on the oh now you're acting different because
you're on camera. If it if it wasn't like the way she delivered
it, that set off like alarm bells to me. I don't know.
>> How is this woman still here? >> I don't know.
I They both want to win. >> I told you to stay away from
me cuz my dog is her dog is behaving and what she's saying. >> Let's
listen. I got to listen again. >> Do you think it was appropriate
for you to try to sick your dog on me? >> I did not. >> Do
you think that was appropriate to stick your dog on me? >> You
sick your dog? I told you to stay away from me cuz my dog is
barking at >> Was that appropriate? Was it appropriate
for you? >> I told you get away from me. Can I talk to
you? >> No. I >> Why did you try to stick your dog
at me? >> I told you to get away. >> You don't like
my political view? >> I told you to get like this. I told
you to following me. Now you're acting different. I told you
to get away from me. I told you to get away from me.
>> I don't think it's that weird. It doesn't strike me
that weirdly. I don't know why
circles like this is very
>> It sounds like Anna is trying to get the uh the racist
thing out of her.
>> Like, why did you stick your dog on me? Oh, you don't
like my political views? Like, she's trying to get the moment
where this person uh came up to me on the streets and commented
that I was
>> I think she wants that moment. >> She might want
it back on camera, maybe. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Yeah.
because no one's she tells that story, no one's going to believe
her because now people are like, "Oh my god, maybe she >> was
never groped or whatever,
>> you know,
>> But I have no idea if the dog was sicked on her at and
I can't say yes or no because this woman's clearly going to be
defensive now that she's being questioned with a phone in her
face. Who admits to guilt like that?
>> Yeah. And she's trying to bait her back into saying
it again. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Yeah.
Maybe
>> it's a very I can believe that Anna was called an antiite.
I can also believe that Anna was groped and that Jimmy door said
that her. So I believe Anna Jimmy say how did Anna go upstairs
to drop off her dog and then come back downstairs and this [__]
still here?
>> Wait, did she drop her dog off? Cuz her I guess her
boyfriend's there or something now, right? >> That's what
she said. She went up, dropped her dog off and that her husband
wanted to see who the woman was. Yeah, >> they probably
want to know which neighbor, right? >> The woman literally
says, "Can I talk to you to the husband?" Right? And he's like,
"No, no, no, no.
>> My dog is barking. Why did you
stalking
at me? Why did you
>> Oh, no. You're a victim. >> You're scaring me.
I mean, I don't know if you She didn't seem scared either as
she like
Can I talk to you? No.
Why did you try to stick your dog at me? >> I told you
to get because you don't like my political views. >> I
told you to get like this. >> I told you to following me.
>> Now you're
listen. Are Are we listening to the voice? Are we Are we hearing
the Are we hearing the voice? >> Why did you try to stick
your dog at me? >> I told you to like my political view.
>> I told you to get like this. >> I told you to
following me.
>> Get away. I'm telling you to get away from me. >> My
dog
that we're going to go to that's
>> It's not really a So you called her a Jew hater.
>> No, it's fine. >> Call me a Jew hater. You called
me a Jew
>> Do you think Anna It would be pretty derange for Anna
to just make that up, right? And put that together. I feel like
I feel like that woman did do that and
and it's so up >> I think the fact that the woman didn't
like say the woman didn't seem like totally confused or outraged
at the idea that it was political or that she was saying do you
hate or so so I think >> because you would turn around
you'd be like no of course >> yeah you'd be like what are
you talking about what are you yeah you'd be like you'd be saying
something >> making something up yeah
>> so um there's another video that we're going to go to
that's going to prove that what I'm telling you guys is True.
Because she told on herself. But go ahead, J. >> So, okay,
>> there's a second video.
There's more. >> She knows.
>> She's waiting for Anna. She's blocking the sidewalk.
>> The best. They're trying to keep the watch time. They're
trying to watch time. This is [__] [laughter] >> splitting
up, bro. The best part. >> Yeah. Do 50% of the video, then
go back to more analysis, and then the other half of the video.
comment about Jupiter. Then she knows about her Anna's husband
and his job and how she's part of a group who's trying to get
him fired for because he has a wife who has m who has criticized
Israel
>> and she thinks she's the victim. >> She thinks
she's the victim. >> Oh my god. Oh, you caught me terrorizing
you. I'm the victim. I'm the victim. Can I make these noise?
Can I
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Did Chank just get
a little bit of an accent there? Did I hear it? >> Terrorizing
you. [screaming] I'm the victim. I'm the victim. Can I make >> Hi,
J. >> I'm the victim. >> Rub his palms. He was about
to rub his >> Are you a streamer? >> Did my
>> Where's Oh, Perry's in here. I was like, did I just
start playing a Perry video? What the >> Yeah, but he's
like a streamer. Why is his microphone at
>> I don't know. >> He's very quiet. >> Came
in to make a joke. So, >> fix your mic, bro. You sound
like you're in a
>> is a joke that you're a streamer with
>> Yeah. Basically, >> he was about to put his palms
together and rub them and it was going to say he was about to
do the pose that Anna got in trouble for. >> That was it.
That was it.
>> I feel like you don't even find your joke funny. >> You
know, you know that Queen Sorry. You know that Perry will be
like totally normal. He'll come on here. He'll talk about things
totally normally if you're not here, right, Queenman? He would
join. He just be like, "What are you guys watching, Shank? But
you're here, so he comes out and does that.
What did you do to this guy?
Why'd you make him this way? >> He's just a I don't know,
man. Very odd >> Like the only bit he'll do the only bit
he'll do when you're there is I'm going to be like
He thinks this is like >> It's like He thinks this was
like an okay story to tell. He told people he he just like said
a story about him assaulting a woman in a bar. Like he punched
some girl in the face in a bar and then tried to run away.
>> Are we going to >> Oh yeah, I remember this. Didn't
he get beaten up for this?
>> I did get beaten up for it. What do you mean not okay
to tell? You're literally a pro cancel culture evil. >> It's
not I'm not being pro cancel culture. It's just like you
>> like even if you did that, you should not feel comfortable
saying that. Don't. >> Wait, is pro cancel culture queen
supporting your bands from like all places and then banning you
from his >> That's one part. >> Wait, he's unbanned.
He's unbanned.
>> Can you fix your mic? >> Yeah, you wouldn't.
>> You're like not coming through for the stream or almost
any of us. Just so you >> chat can't hear you. >> Yeah,
you need to fix.
I don't even know what it's doing. It >> It seems fine
on my end. It >> I just turned you up massively on my stream.
You're going to blow our ears out if you fix it. >> Sorry.
Okay. So, I now I now fixing it is not fixing it now. That's
good. >> No, you can fix it. >> What do you mean
do it anyway? >> It's just so odd. Like Queen is literally
admitting that he's done worse than I have, but he just doesn't
tell the story. That's like so >> not what I said at all.
>> You're saying what did he do? >> I have not done
worse than you have. That's crazy. >> You were the bartender.
You were the bartender. So, you probably like used your power
to pressure a woman into having with you. I bet. And you I wouldn't
tell that story. Weman old enough to serve alcohol?
>> I don't I don't think could get a bartending license.
They just They'd be like Discord. They'd be like, "Send us another
picture." >> Janitor. He would steal He was a janitor.
He would steal clothes and pretend he was cleaning the clothes.
You guys are talking about Chank there. I said the thing. [laughter]
>> I uh >> But it's a I said I felt bad for what
happened and you were like, "Oh, Barry, that's okay. You can't
even say that it's happened." You're like um Cusco in Barry season.
What do you mean you feel bad? You just Why did you punch her?
>> Um I was angry at uh my friend. >> Why were you
angry at your friend? >> And why did that How did that
relate to the girl? >> He was late and they came together.
So I And Oh, [clears throat] and he told that I hit him her and
he hits me. So I was like, "All right, I'm actually going to
hit her now." That's what that's how it went. But yeah, I did.
>> And how hard did you hit her? How hard did you hit her?
>> Uh I don't know. And I never spoke again, so I don't
know how much it hurt. Um Oh, yeah. So, >> in terms of
your power, Perry, how much power did you put in the punch? >> Yeah.
What reaction, what was the reaction like? What was the response
like on her end after you punched her? Like, how did she did
she fall over or >> No. No. She just put her hands on her
nose. I think it was the nose. I hit him in the nose. I say that.
I Whatever. Yeah. So, isn't um what's this guy say? Chank. Isn't
he just doing what Andrew Wilson did for Rob? No. Isn't that
what's happening? Basically,
>> Yeah. Because like you were criticizing Andrew Wilson
Queenman probably because you have dual loyalty but like you
were saying oh he's just uh sweeping for his own but now Chang
does it and it's okay. >> Well no I didn't have an issue
with necessary just backing up your guy. I was saying that I
thought it was a bit gay to like have super strict
rules on
like like you're like exclusive like you only go to places that
support your >> True. And Andrew Wilson says verbatim I
think nepotism is okay. You won't have an issue with that. >> Not
that in of itself. No.
>> Well, I Why not? Isn't that literally saying that you
won't >> I mean I I understand he's like >> I suppose
I mean it's not ideal, but it's like everyone I mean like I thought
most people probably engaged in like slight nepotism.
>> Yeah. But it's like you want to it's like the it versus
super ego, right? You want to be like controlling against it,
but he's like letting he's basically like saying >> why
don't derail into this gay nism argument. Dude, why are you here
to talk about the change or not? Okay, >> I just wanted
to say I was just like lonely. Honestly, I don't want to like
make a big deal of it or anything, but >> Okay. Well, you're
trying to like derail into like a whole like you want to make
this like just us having conversation.
We were watching something
and you >> It's about to take >> I tried to fix my
reactive Discord to include Perry and it just broke for no reason.
So, that's cool. >> Oh, no. >> Give me a second.
Or should you guys get no content cuz uh Perry broke my Discord.
GG.
>> I wanted to make a fat joke, but then I felt bad.
>> Well, can he hear you making the fat joke?
Oh, wait. No, he can't. He can't cuz I'm the only one with a
microphone. You can only hear them. You can't. >> Is there
like a weight limit to the reactive? No, I'm just kidding. Nobody
tell me. >> Jesus. This fix itself. Nope. I have to literally
close OBS if I want to fix it. >> He's trying to fix his
reactive Discord. >> Yeah. No, it's No, it's just not going
to work. It'll never work because reactive Discord is so finicky
now. >> Absolute garbage application. They totally broke
it. They totally broke it for no reason. >> It's complete
trash. >> Uh I could still hear the call, Perry,
even though you couldn't hear me. >> No, no, no, you couldn't.
He said that word. It's
messed up. >> I'm pretty sure he specifically said wet
and but okay, >> there you go. I don't even I'm not racist
enough to know the difference between those tens. So, but yeah.
So, is is Anna winning? That's what I want. >> I came in
to ask is Anna winning
>> got ambushed by some crazy lady in the
>> How do you know they're crazy? >> Just cuz they're
>> she's kind of winning, but >> we saw some video.
Yeah. >> Her husband never made it past minor league in
baseball. So, there is like an L to be had here.
>> Her husband's >> Isn't her husband like a male
model though that was also a baseball player?
>> Yeah, but only minor league. So, it's really difficult
when you like tell people that you're in the minor leagues, but
then it never progresses to major league baseball >> cuz
then you always have to like >> Yeah. Yeah. I stopped after
minor >> Like you tried for a long time and >> now
I teach at like a high school. >> Yeah. That feels really
bad. It's my wife who's famous now. >> It's like you went
to the Olympics, you didn't even win a medal.
>> Actual track. >> It's kind of like skinwalking
destiny, right? Cuz it's like, oh, I only date famous people.
It's kind of [__] up. Like, has she ever dated even
follow
>> I do not follow baseball. >> I couldn't hear what
you were saying,
>> Sorry, Perry. >> If you ever want to fix the mic
or something, it' probably be a great idea. Like, if you >> I
don't I didn't even do anything to it.
>> You're not even attempting to fix it. Like, you're not
listening. You haven't >> I'm looking I'm checking my audio
>> Okay. The volume isn't necessarily the issue. It sounds
like >> Oh, well, just say that. Just say that next time.
>> And also that implies it might not be quiet. So >> it
sounds like you're in a bathroom. >> It does. I saw that
you're like in a
>> cell. We don't really need your mic. You could just
like stop talking. Present to Discord. Show us your DMs with
people. >> Do that. >> Yeah, I could do it. Who should
I start with? That's a good idea. >> Show us your DMs with
um PowerPoint. Show your DMs with Power.
>> No. [laughter] >> Who is that? Someone uses a
lolly avatar, I believe. >> It's a dog avatar.
>> Well, they used to use a lolly avatar. >> It would
be Cub technically. Oh, they did. Oh, okay. I don't I don't want
to screen share, >> Queenman. You're mean. I My audio is
fine. You guys are being mean. >> No, your audio is terrible,
but sure.
>> all right, we're a little ways away. How far are we
away?
>> Where Where are we getting the video? >> She was
anti-Semitic though, right? Like that's what I wanted to say.
>> She was like really she was being >> anti. No,
no. Larry Ellison is really an evil driven person. >> It's
like not that bad. >> She was rubbing the hands
like back and forth and she did the face. She did the >> is
that always anti-Semitic? Isn't it like an evil villain thing
to like rub your hands together? Like it's plotting. It's missing.
>> But it comes from >> the evil villain thing comes
from the antiic trope. That's like saying, "Oh, is it really?"
Well, that's not where it comes from, but >> do you do
you get to get away with being like evil if you're
>> This is what [__] was referring to. There's
like uh they've set up, you know, anti-semitic things everywhere.
>> There's antiic tropes everywhere. It's like, oh, every
single evil trope in the world, if you point at a person, it's
>> But be creative. Just say that. Just say that they eat
their own fecal matter. Just say that they eat they gave their
kids giardia. That's not anti-semitic, but it's an insult. >> Yeah,
it's hate. >> I mean, can you think of a person you throw
that insult at in reality? >> Um, no, I'm just kid. Let
me stop.
>> Probably probably didn't think about Didn't think so.
>> Didn't think so. >> Can I do these hands? [laughter]
Everything's a trope, right? Everything's a trope. You wait like
a thug
ambushing someone and then all of a sudden when they call you
out on it, how do you know my name? How do you know my information?
How do you know my husband? Oh, stop stalking me. Nah, no, no.
By the way, I get notes like this all the >> bro. Chank
Shank's already totally sold on this story, by the way. Shank's
ready to kill this person for Anna. >> Dude, it's so funny
to me when they call white people thugs. >> He's uh >> this
like Karen white woman. You waiting out there like a thug. >> Like
jeez. With that much like gusto on >> Yeah, he's ready
to go. I want a friend like Chank just doesn't even doesn't even
need to see the video. He'll just take my side no matter what.
I don't think women should have special. I think this woman called
her an anti-semite.
>> You think Andrew Wilson would be right as long as he
was only helping women? >> Where's Andrew Wilson in this?
>> Uh, it's just a very obvious onetoone comparison between
Chenk and Andrew Wilson. I don't know what to say. What What
do you want me to say, but do you want to deny it? >> And
Anna and Rob No.
>> Uh, yeah. Yeah. >> What is the onetoone?
Like Anna's being a a petty, you know, brat and then their internet
daddy, Chen, aka Andrew Wilson, is coming to defend them. >> No,
the woman who is Anna's neighbor is not also >> Chank's
employee. >> Chank's employee. Yeah. What are you talking
about?
>> Chank has power over them. He's like trying to get like
he has a news channel. You're saying news channels have no power
over individuals. He wants >> No, we're talking about an
employee
>> Yeah, but he can No, it's about power. Power is power.
Like Chank is not picking between two employees. Chank is not
picking between two employees that are damaging his company.
>> No, he's >> or in like his mind.
>> He's picking his >> Do you actually want to talk
about the Andrew Wilson stuff? Is that what you actually want
to talk about? Is that the problem here? >> It's a one
to comparison. I don't know why you're like pretending it isn't
>> because it's >> I just want I want to give Perry
some time to ingratiate himself with the audience and he's kind
of just throwing he's kind of just throwing completely here.
I don't know why. >> I tried fixing my audio. I couldn't
do it. So, I don't think that's going to
>> Keep saying it's like the Andrew Wilson thing over and
over again. >> Have you have you to your settings and gone
to like where it says like mic test and it says let's check and
you can you can click that >> and like >> Yeah, but
then you want me to deafen myself. You're telling me to [__]
off. >> No, I'm not. It'll definitely yourself for a moment,
but you should you should listen to your own mic >> so
that you can tell what's wrong with it so you can investigate
how to fix it. >> But what if you just start me then? I'll
be upset.
>> I've already [__] you for the time you're
deaf and you go on. >> I made a fat joke about you earlier.
>> All right. One second. >> We do love Perry,
>> but this
>> Yeah, dude. Did he come back even quieter than before?
>> I think [laughter] so. >> I think he came back
quieter.
>> I don't know, man. >> You have to fire. >> I
don't [clears throat] You have to fire. fire. How you are not
allowed to criticize Israel. Yeah, you're doing that. You're
not the victim. You are the aggressor. I'm not talking about
Jewish people at all. I just had literally had both Robert Greenwell,
Ben Cohen, two of the greatest people in this country, fighting
like hell to stop the genocide in Palestine, let alone everybody
who works here, let alone literal family I have. I'm talking
about pro-Israel
radicals.
radicals who think that they are justified to do anything. Terrorize
people, assault people, threaten their lives because we are doing
self-defense.
We are the victims. No, you're not. If you are supporting this
genocide in Israel, you are not at all the victims. You are enabling
everything you said you were against.
>> I grew up in a town that was about half
and I heard things that I love. That's why I love culture. And
we fight for the underdog. We fight for people. >> Wait,
what was that town that he grew up in? Wait, what? Wait, what
town did he grow up in? From Istan.
There's no way he's talking about Istanbul, right?
Was born in Istanbul
and
immigrated to the United States when he was 8 years old.
Okay. East Brunswick, New Jersey. That sounds like a place that
could be pretty heavily. Okay, I believe that one. >> I
believe that one. All right, that >> were oppressed and
never again. And now, >> wait, was his life like the reverse
of Hassan's where he was born in Turkey, then he moved to Jersey.
Hassan's born in Jersey, moves to Turkey, comes back. >> These
pro-Israel radicals who have totally lost sight of that wonderful
tradition and culture coming around going, "Let's threaten people.
Let's fire them. Let's take the media over." You, that was supposed
to be a trope. Now you're doing it. Now you're doing it. Let's
terrorize people. You are not the victim. You are supporting
and enabling one of the sickest genocides I have ever seen. >> Yeah.
So,
a name for genocides right now. Chank.
>> Now, [clears throat] she's denying everything. But what's
really interesting is in the next clip that I'm going to show
you, she uh tells on herself because remember she talked about
how they're trying to get my husband fired. Tell my husband about
it. We go and confront her about what she's saying and what she
did to me. And >> is that okay? >> Who is who is?
>> And uh pay close attention to what she says here. Watch.
>> Wait, wait, wait. You're trying to get me fired. >> No,
I did not. I said I'm telling everybody about her. >> Oh,
that's what she just said. You're trying to >> You You
said that you're trying to get my husband fired. >> Everybody's
trying to get fired. >> Exactly. Yeah, you're part of that,
>> Be careful. That woman's dangerous. She tried to stick
that dog at me. She >> Not a good look to just yell that
across the street at somebody random. Like >> she stick
that dog at me and my dog. That's what she tried to do. That's
what she tried to do. She tried to stick her dog at me and my
dog because she doesn't like my political views. Because I don't
like a genocidal government. >> Wait, [laughter] what did
this woman just come over and she's like, "I'll hold it back.
I'll hold >> because she doesn't like my polit." >> I
got you, Anna. I got you. She'll never do that again. >> Views
because >> what the what? What is this neighborhood? I
don't like a genocidal
So, in the middle of that, you hear her saying, "No, no, I said
everybody's trying to get him fired." Thus,
>> It sounded like she said everybody's trying to get you
fired. And I kind of take that to mean Anna. No. Right. More
than the husband. >> Do we need to watch that again? I
thought it was everybody's trying to get you fired. >> But
her
get her fired, right? She's on >> trying to get me fired.
>> No, I did not. I said I'm telling everybody about her.
>> No, that's what she just said. >> I'm telling
everybody about her. >> You're trying to >> You You
said that you're trying to get my husband fired. >> Everybody's
trying to get him fired.
>> Said everybody's trying to get you fired. But again,
I feel like you to >> I feel like it's got to be referring
to Anna there. >> Yeah. Otherwise, she would have agreed
with him and said, "Well, everyone else is trying to get you
fired."
>> Yeah. You're part of that, everybody.
>> Be careful. That woman's dangerous. She tried to stick
that dog at me. She tried to stick that dog at me and my dog.
That's what she tried to do. That's what she tried to do. She
tried to stick her dog at me and my dog because she doesn't like
my political views because I don't like a genocidal government.
>> She's not scared of that dog. I'm sorry. That did not
work for Anna there. >> No. But also, is that woman like
holding the dog back for Anna? Or do you think she knows the
dog and she was going to pet it? I don't even know.
>> So, in the middle, she's not holding it back. We went
over and pet and went to go pet that dog. >> Like my political
views because I don't like a genocidal government. >> That
dog, that dog definitely knows that woman though. That dog is
like >> because she doesn't like my political views because
I don't like a genocidal
>> So in the middle of that, you hear her saying, "No,
no, I said everybody's trying to get him fired." Thus
>> get you fired. >> What I said earlier, but more
importantly that this woman apparently knows everything about
me. knows who my husband is, know where he works, know
>> uh Toast Masters, you really want to donate, like gift
like a hundred subs right now, you want to go grab your credit
card out of your wallet. >> All right, it'd be really cool
right now. Be like buying a shot for everybody in the bar if
you just gifted 100 subs right now. Okay, I'm just saying it'd
be exactly like that. We'd all go, we'd all cheer. It'd be awesome.
>> Knows about the campaign to try to get him fired. So,
she was standing there in the middle. I walk my dog, and maybe
this is a mistake. I walk my dog at the same time every day.
I have a super packed regimented schedule. I don't want to talk
to anybody when I'm walking my dog. I just want to do what I
need to do to help my dog relieve himself and get back home so
I can get back to work. Okay? I'm not looking for trouble. I'm
not a [laughter] >> Toast Masters. Let's go. 10 gifties.
Let's [__] go. >> Thank you very much, Toast
Masters. Huge >> He's got that blurred vision. So that
zero, he's seeing two of them. He thinks he donated 100. >> Hey,
that's that's a huge >> You basically did. >> I super
appreciate it, buddy. Thank you so much, Toast Masters. >> Is
that two more hours? >> I'm not going to do two more hours.
I don't know if you I I'm I'm literally not capable. I'm like
slurring.
But thank you very much, Toast Masters. >> People I'm not
confronting people. She decided to literally wait in the middle
of the sidewalk with her dog to intimidate me like that. And
when I walked around her, I walked into the street. When I walked
around her into the street in order to avoid her, she starts
approaching me with her dog in a threatening manner and then
acts like she's the victim. >> Okay, look guys, first of
all, that second lady has nothing to do with any of this. Okay,
so leave her out of the Okay, number two, on this lady who costed
Anna, we do not do the same things that they do, okay? We are
the good guys. We don't acost people in the streets. We don't
go stalk them. We don't terrorize them. We're always for nonviolence.
I'm super proud that TYT is now known throughout the internet
as the show that is always for nonviolence. Always for peace.
Okay. So, nobody go bother anybody here because I know what they're
going to do next. Oh my god. They showed it online. >> Oh,
yeah. [laughter] We did. I was just trying to stalk her. >> Did
we sure did. We sure did. I will never apologize for that. You
came for my dog and my husband. You want to come for me? That's
a different story. Okay. Mano Amano, that's a different story.
You come at me with my my dog.
>> I don't even know. >> Now she's doing Joi just
directly on Young Durks. That's pretty up.
>> Did she Did she have the thing where the
>> ill? You shouldn't be saying like that [laughter] in
public. You shouldn't be >> Sherry didn't understand. >> No,
I What did you just say? >> I will never apologize for
that. You came for my dog and my husband. You want to come for
me? That's a different story. Okay, I don't Did she need to do
>> No, this is a very weird segment to be honest with you.
This is a very odd segment in general,
>> dude. Speaking of ill, did you look at that tweet I
sent you? >> somebody tell me what the jerk is. What did
he say? >> Oh, jerk off instructions. She's like, "If you
want to come for me or something like that." >> Oh, okay.
Never mind. >> Ano Amano that you came for my dog and my
husband. You want to come for me? That's a different story. Okay.
Mano Amano, that's a different story. You come at me with my
my dog with my dog. You try to sick your dog at my dog. You try
to threaten my husband's livelihood. You think I'm going to oh,
I'm a little oh wilting flower and I'm so scared. I'm not scared.
I'm not scared. This isn't going to stop me from doing the commentary
that I do. And by the way, look at what kind of disgusting, despicable,
dishonest pieces of crap Canary Mission is. Because while they
were pretending as if I was doing the so-called happy merchant
meme and that I'm some big anti-semite,
let's take a look at the video in full context, shall >> Your
best friends. >> They don't care. >> No, my point
is, did Larry Ellison or Bill Aman or or Netanyahu call her as
>> what the best friend? >> You you have a best friend.
>> Full context. Yes, full context. Your best friend is
>> Hey, are you okay with this? >> Larry Ellison
can tell me how my ass tastes. Okay, how about that? Our disgusting
weird Oracle founder going around talking about like Yes, we're
going to surveil everybody. Everyone will be on their best behavior.
Yes, you're a freak. You're a total creep. >> Okay. [laughter]
All right. Creep. >> So, my point is do not put Larry Ellison's
actions on our friends. >> No, I don't. I don't because
I'm not an idiot. Okay. I don't [laughter] >> dude the
the the profile shot of this is not the best. Okay. >> Best
behavior. Yes. We're going to surveil everybody.
>> Jake's face while she did this is just the perfect.
It's so perfect
the whole time.
Oh Jesus. >> Everyone will be on their best behavior. Yes.
You're a freak. You're a total
>> All right. Total creep. So my point is do not put Larry
Ellis's actions on our >> No, I don't. I don't because
I'm not an idiot. Okay? I don't conflate a nation state with
an entire group of people who have no say in what's going on
in Gaza. No say over what these disgusting billionaires in America
are doing. No, I don't conflate the two because I'm not stupid
and I'm not hateful. Interesting that Canary Mission left that
out. Also interesting that Canary Mission photoshopped this disgusting
okay image onto our background to make it appear as though we
were using that image in our background. They're such disgusting,
dishonest scum.
Scum. They're scum. >> Their job is to terrorize
>> deceptive ratlike scum. Okay. Need to be eradicated
from this >> Americans. Yep. >> And have us bow our
heads [clears throat] to Israel. >> Yep. Because if you
ever say anything against Israel, >> this segment is actually
kind of unhinged.
[laughter] It's funny as but it's it's a little bit >> We
will pretend that you're a hateful even in a clip where we literally
said this has nothing to do with Jewish Americans or friends
and family. They're like, "Sh, don't say that. Don't share that.
Let's just make them look like they're anti-semmites."
And then hopefully someone will do violence against them and
terrorize them and stalk them. Congratulations can Canary Mission
this, you know, this is the fruits of your labor. The death threats
that get >> She could have been Charlie Kirk.
>> She She could have been Charlie Kirk. She could have
been >> Oh my goodness. >> Get the fruits of your
>> life, Jason. >> Yeah. I'm like trying to figure
out what he means there. >> I don't know what he meant.
tried to break the silence and say, "Oh my god, >> Chank's
doing Chank's doing the like uh he's he's playing into the um
>> like f calling people fascist
calling for violence." Yeah. >> Yeah. He's playing like
the wave of like cuz they've been cozing up the magic
>> hardcore going like
that was virtue signaling major on the >> co is shank cooking
that like you should just use this on right-wingers so they realize
they can't use anti-semite the same way that they use fascist
or that they think progressives use fascist. >> Well because
a lot of conservative people love doing that. >> I mean
you could do it on conservatives but that's not what he's doing.
They're just doing it against Israel, right? >> In general.
Yeah. In general. Yeah.
>> That woman conservative. She might be like a Democrat.
>> This doesn't pro. >> This doesn't look good. Jenk
is like, "They left out the part where I specifically said you
have uh your best friend is." They left that out.
I That could be a pickme. You're not You're not really leaving
anything out. If people don't like your caricature,
like sorry, they don't care about the context past it, right?
>> Well, they don't like the caricature. I think the other
thing is I just Yeah, there's nothing else there. >> That
sound like a strong argument. >> Like there's there's some
other
elements there. I guess she's probably mad that people think
she's just like not referring or she's referring to, you know,
some person in general maybe, but it's like Larry Ellison. I
don't know. stronger argument explaining what this person is
doing is like evil rather than saying, "Oh, the the context you're
missing is that her best friend is, so it's fine." >> I
I really thought there was going to be more to the context there
somehow than just that part. But I really think that's the the
context that they think makes it better. Like the rest of it
is just you're some wealthy billionaires and then she's like,
"Well, yeah, this one guy, this one guy." It's like, "Yeah, but
that's like the the IDF's number one funer." So, like when you
claim that it's not about, but you pick the IDF's number one
funer to go after,
I I feel like the only context piece there that helps is just
the best >> And I I feel like there
there have to be powerful that don't support the insane that's
happening, >> Well, the context they're pointing to is
that um they said they don't mean all Americans, they just mean
>> billionaires. Billionaire ones. Are there no good billionaire
ones that are opposed to this genocide? >> I maybe maybe
George Soros. I don't >> I don't know. >> I'm trying
to I'm trying to think of >> but it's >> I I honestly
I know a bunch of like billionaires who are like super behind
Israel like locked in one to one
and then I
>> Who's the uh who's the guy who funds Taylor? Is that
a billionaire?
>> Yeah, but that guy's like Iranian or something, isn't
he? Oh, sure.
What was her fellowship? Her fellowship was
Omidar.
>> There really are no good billionaires. They are like
>> Iranian American. Yeah, >> they are quite incapable
>> to relate to the human experience.
>> Yeah, but that's not >> it has nothing to do with
[laughter] I think that counts, right? If if you're talking about
like >> Yeah. A lot of the
billionaires are probably dual citizens as well, right? So,
I feel like that counts. That counts as an anti
>> No, no, no, no, no. We're talking about Jerry's talking
about at least asking about like billionaires who are against
Israel, who are pro Palestine. And I'm
against Israel, like against the actions of the person running
Israel right now, >> Sure. Well, no, cuz lots of I don't
I don't think that's enough. You should probably be like uh anti-
genocide or something or >> Yeah, like they're anti- genocide.
They're anti the Netany and Yahoo
>> Um but they don't dislike Israel. They probably want
Israel to be something
>> better than what I don't even know if there are any
that aren't just like
like Zionist. Like not even Zionist, like pro-Israel, pro whatever.
Like I I borderline stereotype type pro Israel. >> Yeah.
No, I borderline those feel like they're all greater Israel people.
Like they're just all like, "Yeah, do whatever you want. We'll
we'll support you no matter what." >> It's I feel like
I can totally see it in Larry Ellison's head where it's like,
"Oh, what would be more stable if Israel just has a whole of,"
you know, it's like that. >> But I like I'm trying to think
of one who's not like that. And maybe you could argue it's like
Soros or something. But I don't know if Soros even makes statements.
I don't know. >> Even if she's going to um categorize like
every billionaire, it might be accurate for like the criticisms
that she's having. We don't need to like if there's no hypothetical
one. I mean, if there's no literal one, does she have to like
invent a hypothetical one to not categorize all billionaires?
>> I don't know. >> Just to appease [laughter] the
people. Dude, if all black people are like thugs, do we really
have to entertain the possib
>> you make sure you bring up your black girlfriend, then
you'll be able to. >> No, sorry. It's it's not like that.
I'm saying that like >> the unfortunate thing is is if
you're racist, you would think this, right? >> And but
in reality, billionaire is a small class. I can't name a single
billionaire who's not hyper pro Israel. It's just funny that
it lines up where like racists would make the argument like,
"No, no, no. They all they all do. They all do." >> I think
it just also has to do with the amount of money, a billion. I
don't think you can ever get to a billion dollars and like actually
be in touch with your humanity and give a about the world around
you. >> I mean, I feel that way. I don't know. It seems
like the one guy, the only example I can think of is the who's
the like old investor guy. >> No, no, no, no. It cannot
be the one guy because you would still at a point have so much
wealth that you believe that you are it's necessary in your hands
cuz you're a force of good. So it's necessary for you to acrew
this much wealth so that you can help at least some people in
the world. >> Yeah. I was going to say Warren Buffett was
my example of like I think he signed all of his wealth away and
he >> only has it cuz he basically runs like a
corp or something. I think I think it's Buffett is like the one
guy. I don't know if Cuban or Soros count. I think Cuban Zo is
too big. >> I think Cuban Zo is way too big, >> bro.
I thought Soros might count. I thought Soros might count.
>> Uh, no. Soros is destroying the West. No, these people
they donate money that they never feel is gone.
>> Like when they when they do donations, when they back
people, when they have their little humanity projects, it's it's
not without making sure that they still remain a billionaire,
which is way too many like uh gathered resources for one individual
to really feel like I'm I'm a good person to be in charge of
all of these things. No, you're a little bit detached from the
human experience if you are so cushy as a billionaire. >> I
see what you're saying. I think with some people who have like
companies, you could maybe make this argument >> that like
even even just selling like enough stock in the company to divest
and to be able to give things away. >> Like you might have
to disrupt or you might have to up your company to do it. Like
your company not being in like stable hands might actually be
like a big bigger downside than you having that much money. They're
probably like I I feel like Bezos devesting totally of Amazon
would be like that to like give it away in some way that he would
no longer be a billionaire. I feel like he might disrupt like
a global the global economy in a way that would be unhelpful.
I there's probably some argument like >> I'm not I'm not
so much talking about how do they how do you get rid of billionaires.
It is the individual who gets to a billion that is already detached
from the human experience. Elon Musk deciding after having like
a midlife crisis and taking some mushrooms that he needs to get
to Mars. So, he's going to gather up all of the resources on
Earth. >> I see what you're saying. >> And try to
be like in control of it because he is more enlightened than
the rest of humanity. >> That is like every billionaire.
They just don't all get to Elon's level of I'm going to speak
out my evil plots like Mojo Jojo. >> Yeah. Sure. Sure.
Sure. Okay. I guess then yeah, I'd probably say no billionaire
in that case. Definitely not Soros and Soros crashed the British
pound just to make his money. Say you just if you just have to
have like a level of
disdain or lack of concern for humanity to take advantage of
people that much that you can acrewue that much >> to be
at Bezos level to be at his success and people were peeing in
bottles because they didn't want
to waste any time between clicks of like packaging orders in
Amazon warehouses is insane. These people are just gross
and they blink sideways. >> Lizard truly lizard people.
Um,
>> that's some Vosian argument, I guess. I'm not I'm not
a commie. I just >> I seriously
seriously loathe specifically attack billionaires, but like all
billionaires >> apparently. Uh,
apparently the one guy who's a big like well fan YMS's former
editor, big food shops fan, >> one guy's a >> guy
in the in the general chat of my discord just said he's got that
Dan bod where Dan talks about how you got to lie to get your
way >> like he'll lie about to do anything like he'll lie
and do anything to get his way. Like he just posted posted. Sorry
I up saying it. He's like a
fan as in he loves food shops. He also is like a Dan fan and
he also is like a furry and YMS's editor for one of his clip
channels. Let's watch it. I don't think he's offering it. I don't
think he would give it away. >> Oh, I was going to say
why if he's a fan of all those people, why'd he post it?
>> I think he just wants to go like I have >> Yeah,
that's the point of the Martini thing, right? He's posting an
edit of >> Yeah, true. I didn't even think about the Martin
Scrley thing. Got him.
Although, that actually gives me a good idea of where that VOD
would be from. Let's go.
Wait, is that the VOD? Yeah, I know. I know.
Very nice. Very nice. Yeah. Suddenly everybody's like, "Oh, it's
that VOD." Oh, cool. The death threats that Anna gets and that
I get the fruits of your labor. You must find out. You have to
play that live. You have to play it live and just rub it in this
lo's >> Your job to terrorize
Americans into compliance with Israel. I would love to know and
I every reporter in the country should be asking if they didn't
all work for goddamn Israel where the funding for Canary Mission
comes from. Where does it come from? Where who are the people
trying to terrorize Americans and say if anyone in your family
ever criticizes beloved Israel in the middle of a genocide will
have your family members stalked. We'll have your family members
fired. Will ruin your life. Now look guys, we're tough and strong
and and and >> we're not going to stop. >> No, no,
no, no. >> We're not going to stop here. >> Hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. We're not going to stop. >> So we're
not going to stop. I get it. God knows what they're going to
do to us. God knows what they're going to do to us. Okay.
>> But I run into Now we're talking about normal Americans
here. Christians has nothing to do with Palestine. Anna has nothing
to do with Palestine. They're not Muslim. They're not Arab. They're
not anything. Okay? So they And by the way, we shared a report
with you guys last week. I have an update on that maybe I'll
share later in the week about groups now trying to get normal
Americans fired from work for supporting Palestine in social
media. Not attacking Israel, let alone,
but just somebody put a Palestinian flag in their Facebook pro
profile. Concerned effort, rando, total random American. You
have to fire her. She's an anti-semite.
Fire them. Israel is the >> bro. Like
there's such hatred for these people in Shank's voice. I feel
like he's being anti-semitic with no tropes whatsoever. Like
there's just such anger and hatred for these exact people. I
feel like I feel the anti-Semitic energy radiating off of him
without having any actual idea.
>> It's like
of cancel culture and they [laughter] have and they keep just
pressing down and pressing down on all of America. You better
not criticize. You better follow Israel's >> Sarah stream
is still up and it's over.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I I Yeah, we might go check out the
Saravead. I could go check out the Saravead.
>> You better give us another $300 billion. I'm not That's
We should not give a single dollar to Israel. Zero. Is that anti-semitic?
Yeah, of course they are. They're going to say, "If you don't
give us $300 billion, you hate Jews. Are you insane?
You're driving anti-semitism.
Cut it out. You're endangering
American across the world with your vicious te efforts to terrorize
anyone who criticizes Israel. No, we're not going to stop. But
most people, I mean, I run into Muslim Americans. They're like,
I can't say anything. I'm an American citizen. I came here for
freedom and I cannot say a word online cuz if I say one thing,
hey, could you please stop murdering children? No. Way too much.
Could you please stop judicial
treatment? I'm sick of them having that special level of entitlement
where our constitution somehow doesn't apply to us when it comes
to critique of Israel. No, I'm not going to give them that pleasure.
They don't deserve it. And if you have a listen, if you have
a problem with Americans being critical of Israel because Israel
is the most important thing in the world to you, please, by all
means, go live in Israel. Go live in Israel. leave this country
to the warm-blooded Americans who actually believe in our constitutional
rights. >> And by the way, that includes >> going
too far. I feel like um
>> does that doesn't it feel like the Democratic Party
was starting to take uh Gaza that more serious and convince,
okay, maybe there is a famine. Okay, it is being considered a
genocide by the UN. They're like they're open to the criticism.
And now the response is let's play into every negative stereotype
and like make it hyperbolic.
So it's like off-putting again. >> Um I think they're going
a little too far. I don't know if like any of the mainstream
politicians really feel that way. Probably the Democratic base
feels this way. >> Feels like they're going too far that
would, you know, give people enough to
Yeah, these lefties are just anti-semitic. I just I've never
seen anybody start to have the tides changing in their favor.
So they're like >> and now I'm going to get more angry
and more aggressive. And >> I feel like you're describing
exactly how populists and like demagogues work as in like oh
people are starting to be on my side but you don't really have
like a plan. You didn't really have anything to like literally
your brand is being the outsiders being the people who are like
this isn't far enough. And so naturally they'll be naturally
inclined to continue to go more extreme as in like this isn't
far enough, this isn't >> I feel like that's Tit's position.
They like being on the outside looking in. If the if the Overton
window shifts towards them, I think they'll start shifting more
extreme. Now, I don't know if that's necessarily happening here,
but I do believe that's Yeah.
>> Yeah, I do believe that's kind of what you could see
going on here. I'm not 100% sure. Like I think they are going
too far. I'm just saying in terms of
I guess with Ann, I'd maybe lean more in that direction where
she could be
pushing it to the place where they could call her anti-semitic.
Yeah. >> Americans, Muslim Americans, Christian Americans,
every kind of American. But if you're like, "No, I I worship
Israel." There's a great way to worship Israel by going to Israel.
Okay. So, >> dude. Okay. That
you if you love Israel, just go to Israel. Okay. If you're wondering
why I'm so animated in my country, >> they've also threatened
my family and the other day I got an email saying, "You're already
dead. You just don't know it." >> So these are the terrorists
that work inside America on behalf of Israel.
So if I do die, by the way, it was definitely someone who was
in favor of Israel. Maybe this [laughter] is the legal mindset
attack, dude. He's doing the legal mindset attack. Let's go.
He got an email. Uh boy. Uh I think you Jerry I think you were
right. Um they are going too far. It is getting a little absurd.
>> The Israeli government itself. Now why do I say oh you're
>> wait this is just like a legal mindset video. It's uh
it's it's the woke ugly woke white women stalking
him through the streets. And then
you somebody to be angry at
attacking you.
>> I don't know. >> Crazy.
I
dude TYT's like content recently, every time I watch a TYT video,
people are like, "This video is like kind of crazy." And then
I watch it and it's like a hundred times worse than I thought
it could possibly be.
>> Takes uh blood pressure medication every >> I
probably just on the days that he's yelling like this. >> Uh
I got to imagine it's every day at this point. He is like >> really
government itself. Although maybe he just like swims or something
cuz he's got he's got like lung capacity like you wouldn't believe.
This guy doesn't take a breath. He just screams like this for
>> Now why do I say oh you're anti-semitic? They literally
said they wrote an email. You are already dead. You just don't
know it yet. And this is on behalf of
>> So who's the terrorist
>> by the way? >> Who who killed 20,000 children?
Who has a worse civilian
ratio than or any other terrorist group in the world? IDF. Israel.
Who has done at least 70 October 7th? Israel. Yep.
Israel. There's wonderful Jewish Americans fighting against that
today here in America. And I love them for it because you know
why? They're Americans. Yep. And they're good, decent people
who actually listened in synagogue and temple and learned the
actual faith of Judaism and not this nationalistic sick Zionism
that demands obedience and terrorizes the whole world. And if
>> wait, why what?
Oh, what is this tweet? >> Anyone dares disagree with their
>> Then they get accused of the worst things in the world.
They try to end their careers. They they've been terrorizing
this country for year after year, decade after decade. And we're
sick of it. The left's sick of it. The right is sick of it. The
whole country is sick of it. The only puppets, oh no puppet,
trope, trope, trope, trope, trope, trope. That still work for
Israel. Oh, he said work for Israel. Yeah, goddamn right I did.
90% of Congress gets money from the Israeli lobby. Yes, it's
legal, but that is legalized bribes. And everybody knows it.
We know it when big pharma does it. We know when big oil does
it and we know when Israel does it. We see you now. We see you.
You're buying all of our politicians. That's why people like
Cory Booker are like, "Oh, Apac. I didn't know what Apac is."
Oh, give me a >> He did it. He did it. >> That's
why people like Cory Booker are like, "Oh, Apac
doesn't hit >> Apac is Oh, he only gave me a tiny
>> Why Why is he like a what's it called? A T-Rex. It feels
like it's difficult for his hands to meet each other. [laughter]
>> Israel, I love Israel. I love Israel. I bow down to
Israel. We see you, Cory Booker. We see you, Democrats. We see
you Republicans and yes, mainstream media. Most of all, we see
you doing
for Israel decade after decade. Today in the news, Israel slaughters
And what New York Times reporting? Well, they say that the IDM
soldiers. Well, did it? You're the New York Times. You're supposed
to give us the truth. It turns out they didn't. It was one of
their own unexloded bombs. But the New York Times didn't tell
you that. The New York Times said, "Oh, broke the ceasefire.
Bunch of liars. Mainstream media, we see you. We see that you're
working for Israel. You're the most biased people."
>> I don't know. I don't know. I literally don't know >> what
is this.
>> Am I crazy? Am I >> I don't know what you showed
me. I >> I don't know. What? What is the book? >> Is
that not like I thought that was like a a phrase about how women
are
>> No. No. The This is the Britney Simon book. What the
>> It's the Britney. Look at the top left. >> I knew
I recognized her from somewhere, >> It's the Britney Simon
book. The body keeps score.
Stop doing memes. Fine. >> Why do you call it the Britney
Simon >> Cuz she talked about this is how she had her like
blow up with Destiny. She was referencing this book about how
like trauma affects you no matter what for a long period of time.
Body keep score.
Sorry. I was looking at uh one of the snark group chats and they
posted this tweet. We've been together. Whether you've been together
seven days or seven years, it's important to continue mastering
the art of seduction. >> That's me.
>> Oh, wait. Hold on. Maybe it's actually what he does
in the video. Hold on.
>> Watch me do this back flip. >> Oh, it's her. It's
Oh, it's going to be
>> was uh pretty good. >> That's actually a funny
clip.
>> Touch W in this one case. Okay. >> Not going to
give him a lot of >> That book is that is the Britney Simon
reference book. And that >> Yeah, that is the Britney Simon
book.
>> 100% it is. Okay.
Does that mean that uh does >> that mean what? >> No,
no, she didn't write the book, Queman. She just references >> Oh,
no. I know. I know that. >> Okay. Okay. >> But like
why do why do people What's that book about? Why do they read
that? >> Trauma staying in like the body.
>> Basically, like how trauma affects you whether you know
it or not. >> This was basically Yeah. When Destiny said
uh something like, "Oh yeah, I could see how you could be like
raped and it not really affect you at all." That was
I don't know that was like >> there's a lot of people who
are not in touch with their feelings or
or [__] like that that don't realize how trauma affects
them.
>> Yeah. And that like your body will break down in other
ways like you'll have like you'll suddenly develop like ulcers
or some [__] >> if you don't like process the
trauma like directly and properly. >> Yeah. There are people
who have had like panic attacks that don't know that they're
having panic attacks. >> Yeah. And so >> cuz they
just think that that's woman. >> That was the idea was
Britney was saying if you don't process this stuff it'll come
out in other ways and you should read the body keep score.
>> Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. >> Dude, I'm sorry.
I I saw that tweet and I was just like it was goofy. >> What
you want to get? I didn't know the happy merchant meme either.
Okay. So now I know it. Thank you. I appreciate
>> So now I know it and
learn this or or realize this Israel. Now I know the happy merchant
meme and now I've mastered it. Okay. >> Trump 90%
Congress gets money from the Israeli lobby. Yes, it's legal,
but that's real. I love Israel. I don't know what Apex There
we go. Okay. I didn't know what the happy merchant meme was,
but know this is real. I've mastered it now and I will use it
appropriately. Oh, he only give me a tiny Oh, I love today. There
there is something to be said for Anna's Anna. Unfortunately,
Bro, the everything about the way Anna did it was just >> No,
Anna. Anna and Candace Owens, they're just like they're on another
This is this isn't it from Jenk. But I >> she's not doing
a good job. Anna somehow perfectly embodied like the meme >> and
performance with 10 out of 10. Jenk is a real one for doing it
too cuz it's like well you guys better have heat for me too.
>> This is this is his I'm Spartacus moment when he put
his hands together there. >> Fix that out for her on Yeah.
You want to [laughter] you want to you want to cancel? I know
you got to come for me, >> appreciate it. You know what?
I'm now going to call this the Larry Ellison. Not about you,
not even about Israel. This one is just about Larry Ellison.
Okay. So, when you see that son of
>> to make sure that no one's allowed to criticize Israel
and take away our First Amendment rights on behalf of his
>> then you do this.
Okay. Goody. [laughter] >> Dude, this guy's out of his
>> You guys, this is our hate symbol. >> Dude, what
the [__] is >> I'm making a dog whistle. [laughter]
You rub my hands together to symbolize the rich cable.
>> I just go up with this, guys. I'm calling this one the
Larry Ellison. >> I didn't do the meme. I didn't do the
meme. I'm just saying this. Okay, this is the Larry Ellison.
Hey, give me Tik Tok. Work for Israel. Give me CBS. Work for
Israel. [laughter] He was the American government. He bought
Marco Rubio for $5 million.
Let me buy your company [laughter]
>> No way. >> Donald Trump. He sure did. >> There's
a We got his emails, leaked
>> What is What is he doing? >> Says reports back
to the Israeli ambassador. If you're going to report back to
an Israeli ambassador, go live in Israel. Get the hell out of
our country cuz you don't love this country. [laughter] Like,
let's let's just be real. He's 100% saying, Larry Ellison, your
country is Israel. If you love Israel, get the [__]
out of here. Look at me do the Larry Ellison, the evil seeing
Jews [laughter] all the media, all the companies.
He's just said these things explicitly.
What are we Oh, boy. >> He told people to do that symbol,
that that gesture, too. He's like, "You guys do this. Do this.
>> This is the Larry Ellis. Do this." >> Oh, holy
[__] >> You love Israel. So, what did he do?
I bought him for $5 million. He didn't say bought. He said, "I
checked to see if he was pro-Israel. He passed my test, so I
sent $5 million to a super PAC." >> Rubio was buying Marco
Rubio. And it was a good purchase because he's now Secretary
of State and works for Israel. So that's how politics is in this
country. It isn't about just Israel. It's about all the lobbies
and all the donors who buy all of our politicians and the media
who covers it up and goes, "Oh, don't worry about the money.
Don't follow the money. Don't follow the money. It's anti-Semitic
to follow the money." No. Bow your head. to Israel, bow your
heads to big farmer and defense contractors and to all the donors.
Well, we're not bowing anymore. We're not bowing. Hey, Larry,
go stuff this in your trope uh treasure chest or whatever the
hell you keep your nonsense things. And I'm sure he'll come after
us cuz he's so rich and he loves to use his money to bully [laughter]
people and to terrorize people in this country. That's what I
think of Larry Ellison. [laughter] every time you ring the bell
>> The slam is so fun. >> Chang such a passionate
guy, man. My god. Oh,
I just This is literally the first thing I thought after listening
to that was like, "Oh, Ch's feeling a lot of pressure. He knows
that Sneo and Nick Fentes are both getting unbanned. He's feeling
pressure right now." Jesus.
Oh, man. And I didn't expect that video to be so awesome. Out
of nowhere,
this supposed to be about Anna's dog.
You might have seen antis rand demanding that you're not being
[laughter] antis all time. >> Oh, holy [__]
Okay. All right. Well,
um, that woke me up a little bit. I might check out a little
bit of the start of this Sarah. I'll just see if she goes into
any of the >> We can do it off stream. >> We could
do it off stream.
We could
um hold on. >> That way I can get a lot of these like slurs
off my chest.
>> Okay. I don't know. Uh maybe do supporter stream for
a little bit, guys. I don't know how long we're doing for >> Did
this guy find the dang clip or not?
>> Uh he won't. >> I can ask Tom Bronson.
But I I think uh I think that imaginary fanboy guy is lying to
begin with because if I look at the like maybe but I feel like
if I look at this [__] this is us watching um some
clip on my stream and it's be very vivic cherry and me and I
feel like when we talked about this I feel like Queen was here
when we actually talked about when when like this specific clip
I'm thinking of when we're hearing Dan talk about how you can
lie and say whatever you want. I feel like Queen was there but
Todd Bronson doesn't have it right. the one where I told Dan
like you're in your Karen bag.
>> Uh, it could be. I don't know if Dan comes on for this
one cuz it's He says it's a like a Dan VOD, but I don't see Dan
there. That's like Dan.
>> That's like a video we're watching of Dan, not literally
Dan.
>> like Dan's icon isn't there. >> Okay. I have no
idea what you're looking at. So, >> Oh, hold on. I'll pull
up the picture. I think I sent it to you. It was like this picture
with Shreley or whatever, right? This is like a VOD of mine,
but Dan's not here. It's Cherry. It's be very vivic and me. So
like Dan isn't even here on this VOD right now.
>> Yeah, Porter Bella remembers it. It's uh was he talking
to Kidn? I mean, he talked to Kidn back here. We were definitely
talking to Dan. Like me and Quimman. were like, "Hey, you shouldn't
lie cuz it'll come back and get you eventually." And he's like,
"No, no, no. You should just say whatever is the most effective
thing at any given time and it doesn't matter what the truth
is." Anyway, if anyone has that VOD, be interested in that one.
All right. Um, yeah, probably go to like a what do you call it?
Patreon stream for a little bit. Check out this Sarah the Raging
tomato vod. See if there's anything there. And then maybe we'll
cover it tomorrow if there's if there's some >> That way
we don't just like watch the LOL parts on stream. >> Yeah.
Yep.
Yeah, sure. Um, if you guys want to join, there's the Patreon.
patreon.com/jok.
I think we'll do just supporters. All right. patreon.com/jok.
All right. Thank you guys for being here
I'm trying to show the Patreon, but it's there somewhere. Hold
on a second. >> Exclamation point. Patreon. Does that do
anything? It's not
>> Does this Patreon have like >> revenge sessions
or something? Like >> I've heard that. Yeah. Gabe Reviews
prevent something like that. >> They like go to the homes
of content creators on Google Street View and said they're analyzing
them with people. NVC
>> apparently. I' I've heard this. I've heard people say
like this. Uh if you want to, you know, some some guy I won't
say the full name. Some guy named LH may have the proof of this.
Okay. This guy hangs out in certain Discords.
He'll have the proof of this. Did Cherry do the happy merchant
meme off camera? No, not on camera either. Never ever. She's
never done the happy merchant meme. She didn't even know it.
Chud must be a top tier sub. Well, we've never watched any trans
or the gay reviews, so no, he uh he doesn't hang out.
Just never happened.
All right, I'm gonna we can sign out here. Thank you everybody
for being here tonight. I'll be back tomorrow. Oh, I'm not 100%
back tomorrow. We'll see. We'll have to see here.
>> All right, we'll talk to you guys later. Bye-bye. Good
night. Good night. Good night. Good night. Good night.